I actually felt really insecure about
this I choreographed that myself and I
think it's very obvious that I'm not a
dancer Wednesday's iconic dance has all
of the internet in a Chokehold do you
know the original story behind it did
you know that Jenna Ortega was majorly
sick when she filmed it or that she
pulled it together at the last minute it
was really awkward but only because I
make things awkward number one did you
know the original idea for the dance was
a flash mob can you imagine Wednesday
Adams in collaboration with the entirety
of Nevermore Academy on a dance I break
out into hives and then the flesh peels
off my bones Jenna Ortega was actually
the one to vouch for Wednesday doing a
dance on her own I thought no there's no
way Wednesday would be cool dancing and
encouraging a bunch of people after she
talked it over with Tim Burton he agreed
to let her do her own thing that was
really cool for me number two Jenna
wouldn't consider herself a dancer much
less a choreographer she does like to
have ownership over physical aspects of
her characters and Tim Burton refused
used to work with a dance choreographer
so it seemed more than appropriate for
Jenna to take the task on herself but
how much did she prepare we'll get into
that in a second after seeing everything
she had on her plate oh my God I was
kicking myself I felt like such a fool I
was like I'm not a dancer I don't do any
of that she has no experience in that
field at all what do you think would you
have known oh wow that's like a hidden
talent number three we wouldn't dare
call Jenna a procrastinator she was just
super busy I was doing cello that week
fencing that week I just didn't have
time Tim Burton comes up to Jenna in her
trailer I know you said that you wanted
to choreograph the self because ever
this yourself because I refuse to see
choreographer this was only two days
before shooting the scene he was like I
know you got it you've been working on
it I'm not even worried about it I trust
you she in fact hadn't been working on
it at all and I said oh yeah you know
it's all so good and I had not gone over
it at all number four Jenna didn't sleep
for two days trying to figure it out she
watched Allah lot of videos of Susie and
the Banshees I like Lena Lovich I think
she's a weirdo and she had a lot of
really interesting music videos she even
found hours of archival footage of goth
kids dancing in clubs in the 80s it's
nice to kind of see them enjoy
themselves a little bit and I took some
of the stuff that they do and added it
towards the end just she was also really
inspired by Fosse I had seen some of his
films in the past so I took a little bit
of inspiration from him as well number
five we're not talking about Christina
Ricci who plays Marilyn Thornhill on the
show my name is Nick or Laurel Gates
whatever you want to call her she played
Wednesday back in the 90s the baby
weighs 10 pounds The Cannonball weighs
20 pounds which will hit the stone
walkway first we're going all the way
back to Lisa loring's original Wednesday
dance from the 60s did you catch that
classic inspiration you learn how to
dance well she'll think your boss number
six it was Jenna's first day with kovid
the day of the dance shoot so it was
awful to film and I asked to redo it but
we didn't have time she woke up that day
with major body aches and a sore throat
but she didn't know she had covet until
after because they were waiting on test
results I felt like a little Goblin had
been let loose in my throat and was just
scratching the walls of my esophagus
number seven there was actually quite a
bit of it we mentioned before that a big
inspiration behind Jenna's moves was
Susie and the Banshees I feel kind of
bad because I kind of I ripped off a
couple of her moves she used a few of
Susie's moves as improvised filler in
between some of her other choreographed
moves where she's just going like this
for a really long time and she's just
singing at the stand or whatever and I
did that as filler those moves proved to
be useful while she was waiting for
another move or a camera movement
because I just had to throw stuff in
there to kind of improvise number eight
that song was picked by both Jenna
Ortega and Tim Burton Jenna read the
script for episode 4 pretty early on but
they didn't have any idea what kind of
dance they wanted or even what song to
play the a week before we shot the dance
he um chose the song gugumok by The
Cramps Jenna actually was pretty ahead
of the game and made a playlist with
potential songs for the dance number and
the cramps is one of my favorite bands
ever so I was super excited super pumped
it was on my episode four playlist did
you know there were so many behind the
scenes tidbits about Wednesday's dance
number we're even more impressed after
finding out Jenna Ortega choreographed
it last minute all while being
incredibly sick and with no prior Dance
Experience what's your favorite behind
the scenes fact about it